but this sounds pretty aggressive what's
going on here why is that well everybody
is kind of looking at what's going to
happen with cars and as Jim Higgins
wrote in his scoop you know today Apple
is looking to diversify their product so
this is it's an interesting approach
Google's already in this space you have
Tesla which is seen as more of a Silicon
Valley company than an automaker who's
already there everybody's looking to see
what the future of the car is going to
be and because of all the changes
there's really no guarantee that it will
be GM Ford Chrysler or Volkswagen any of
the traditional players so that's kind
of the space they're coming into it's
already in turmoil it's already shifting
it is kind of a wide open space for
whoever you know kind of has the best
idea it really is and when we think of
electric cars of course Jeff and we're
showing one right now in our screen we
think of Tesla but they are far still
far away from producing a mass
production electric car I mean who's
furthest ahead in that area Jeff well
there's a big risk that that no one
actually gets there because so far
consumers aren't that interested in it
well you have the leaf from Nissan which
is probably the closest thing to a
mass-market electric car as much as
there's mass involved and there are a
lot of risks to this I mean the amount
of time that Apple is going to take to
bring a car is really short and Toyota
and Honda and other automakers have
gotten in trouble when they started to
shorten their development times and had
the link from them out a little bit
that's where some of these recalls we've
been dealing with in the last few years
came from when they got a little sloppy
and took too little time to work out the
kinks so there's always risks when
you're making a car it's not likely your
iPhone is going to kill you but cars you
know are a lot more dangerous they are
indeed all right Jeff a lot goes into
building a car as we know Jeff green
thank you so much our Detroit bureau
chief